دعونا لا نكون ساذجين بشأن هذا على الرغم من أننا
نعيش في عصر حيث
الدوري الممتاز هو علامة تجارية عالمية ،
فهو ضخم للغاية سواء كنت
تتحدث عن
آسيا أو إفريقيا أو في أمريكا ، سيظل المشجعون
يشاهدون هذا
، إنه أمر محزن ومحبط
لكرة القدم الحقيقية  الأصوليون لكن غالبية
مشجعي كرة القدم في ذهني
لن يلتفتوا تمامًا لمشاهدة
الفرق الكبرى تلعب ضد بعضها البعض
أسبوعًا في الأسبوع ، وسيكون هذا
عرضًا لكرة القدم الذي من شأنه أن يرى
هذه الفرق تلعب سواء في آسيا
أو إفريقيا
أو  في أي مكان آخر في ما يسمى بألعاب الدوري ،
أنا أحتقر ذلك تمامًا ،
فأنا لا أحبه على الإطلاق ولكن يمكنك أن تكون على
يقين من أن المشجعين في جميع أنحاء العالم الذين
يشترون هذه القمصان ويدعمون النجوم
سوف ينضمون إلى شيء مثل
هذا لرؤية عمل جيد
كل أسبوع ولكني أفكر
قبل حدوث أي شيء كهذا
وسيكون التاريخ المقترح هو
عام 2022. أعتقد أن هناك العديد من القضايا
القانونية وهناك فوضى شديدة
في تخزين هذا الأمر للمضي قدمًا وهل نحن
على افتراض أن أي فريق يشترك في
هذا
إذا تم المضي قدمًا فعليًا سيتعين عليه
ترك
الدوري الممتاز وراءه أو البطولات المحلية
في إيطاليا
وإسبانيا أو في أي بلد آخر
يرغب في المشاركة ، فإننا نفترض
أنه سيتعين عليهم المغادرة  دوري الأبطال ،
لم يتمكنوا من العودة إلى
ذلك النوع من الضرر
الذي سيتركهم في أعقابهم ، نعم ، لقد كان الاتحاد الأوروبي لكرة القدم (UEFA) و FIFA (
فيفا)
سريعًا جدًا في إصدار تصريحات
ليقولوا الكثير ليخرجوا
ويطوقوا هذه
الفكرة تمامًا وحتى الذهاب  أبعد من ذلك
، تحدثنا عن الاتحاد الأوروبي لكرة القدم والفيفا حول
حظر اللاعبين من المنافسة الدولية ،
هل يمكنك أن تتخيل أنه مع اقتراب
كأس العالم في
عام 2022 في قطر ، سيكون لديك
لاعبون لن يُسمح لهم
بتمثيل
بلدهم و  نحن نتحدث
عن أفضل اللاعبين في العالم هنا ، العبوا
لهذه
الأندية ، واو ، لا يمكن لهذا الأمر أن يصبح
فوضويًا بشكل خطير ،
لكن هذا حقل ألغام قانوني ، أليس
كذلك إذا كان لديك عقد  للعب
مع أحد هذه
الأندية وهم ينطلقون ويفعلون شيئًا آخر ،
أعني أين تقف ، من
المفترض أن تتبع ناديك ،
ما رأيك كيفن هل
سيحدث ذلك.
لا يمكنني السماح للمال بالفوز
في مثل هذا الموقف
الذي مررنا به في أكثر الأعوام صعوبة
في أي من عصرنا على هذا
الكوكب الآن
وشاهدنا أندية كرة القدم تتقدم
ولا أتحدث فقط عن الكبار
هناك
أتحدث عن أندية الدوري الأصغر
التي أقامت ملاعبها
لتكون
بنوك طعام أو مراكز تطعيم ، وقد
رأينا كرة القدم تزدهر حقًا في
مجتمع يزدهر حقًا
، ولكي يظهر هذا في وقت مثل
هذا ،  إنه أمر محبط بشكل لا يصدق
لدرجة أن
الناس ما زالوا موجودين داخل كرة القدم
يريدون تحقيق ذلك